abby and ben did household chores last
weekend together they earned fifty
dollars let me underline that together
they earned fifty dollars and abby
earned ten dollars more than ben let me
underline that as well
abby earned ten dollars more than ben
how much did each earn now we could just
go and solve it but it looks like they
want us to ask they want to ask
something else if you were to use the
graph above which strategy is most
useful in helping you find the answer to
the problem so we don't even have to
solve for it they just want us they just
want us to tell them what is the best
strategy for solving the problem so the
first choice they say finding an
equation for the blue line so let's look
at this graph that they've also given us
so the blue line here is the graph that
using the information that abby earned
ten dollars more than ben that's what
that says it's written a little bit
small but hopefully you could see it
abby earned ten dollars more than ben
which is this information over here and
so if you call this over here the b axis
for the amount been earned and this is
the a axis for the amount abby earned
the equation of this line would be
abby
abby is equal to the amount abby earned
is going to be ten dollars more than the
amount ben earned so that's the equation
of that line right there well that by
itself isn't going to help you figure
out how much did each earn so that by
itself won't solve the problem
finding the red line's y-intercept so
let's look at the red line the red line
is using the information that abby and
ben earned fifty dollars combined it's
this information up here and the
equation of that would be abby's
earnings plus ben's earnings are equal
to 50 dollars if you were to just find
the y-intercept there it's just at 50
that's really not giving you any
information and figuring out how much
did they each earn and actually solving
for a and b so b by itself won't work
finding the line's points of
intersection now that's interesting
because the point of intersection gives
you
it gives you so let me let me
circle that a little bit bolder let me
do it an orange in a magenta color
so the point of intersection right there
that gives us an a and b value that will
satisfy both equations and if they're
satisfying both equations it'll satisfy
both constraints
so if we just eyeball it off this chart
it looks like b is equal to 20 and a is
equal to
a is equal to 30. and if we just use
these numbers relative to this together
they earned 50 dollars that works if
abby earns 30 and ben earns 20 they'll
earn 50
and 30 is 10
more than 20. so this worked by looking
at the points of intersection we were
able to figure out how much abby and ben
earned so i would go with c we don't
even have to read d but they say you
cannot tell how much they earned because
there are two lines on the graph no
that's that's complete silliness right
there so the choice is c